hi there steve kaufman here today to
talk again about languages and uh
if you enjoy these uh videos please
subscribe and don't hesitate to give me
a like it's all good for my uh rating
which i guess i'm supposed to be trying
to push
but today i want to talk about verb
conjugations because this comes up in a
number of different languages and it's
certainly something that i'm
encountering in turkish
and i want to show you how i deal with
it
a couple of housekeeping things we are a
month away or a little more than a month
away from the long fest in montreal i
think it's going to be the best ever i
was talking to tetz who
one of the organizers there
and to remind you to register if you
haven't already done so and you will get
a discount if you use as your access
code steve my name steve can be
uppercase lowercase it's not case
sensitive i will leave a link to the
long fest here in the description box
another sort of housekeeping thing i had
a
podcast interview with chris
broham of actual fluency
talking about seniors learning languages
and stuff i will leave a link in the
description box please go there if you
are interested in hearing this
discussion chris is an awfully nice guy
someone that i met for the first time i
think in montreal at the long fest a few
years ago
so
conjugations all right so i just
finished by the way my fourth
uh online discussion with the tutor we
chatted for an hour
uh i thought i had recorded it in zoom i
can't find the recording anywhere on my
computer
when i eventually manage to record one
of these i will
show you my state after
six weeks of turkish what i struggle
with most is turkish verbs because the
verbs in turkish embody not only tense
but also probability likelihood
negative positive a whole bunch of stuff
gets thrown in there in a way that i'm
not used to i'm used to the way verb
conjugations work in
european languages even farsi uh greek
uh even arabic was not as strange as to
me as the sort of turkish way where
everything gets thrown into these verbs
before i and i'll show you how you know
on on
on my computer how this works
uh
i also want to talk very briefly about
i'm going to somebody asked to show an
example of a tutors report so i have my
session with my tutor and then i get a
report with an audio recording i'll show
a little bit of that as well on my
computer but talking about conjugation
so
one of the things i do because if you
look at a conjugation table at least i
find that there's no way i'm going to
remember the conjugation table i can
look at it many many many times
i mean this first i became
first aware of the fact that looking at
tables doesn't do it when i was learning
german and i was trying to remember the
declension tables and i just couldn't do
it and so i just gave up and basically
realized that if i focused less time on
trying to memorize the declension tables
if i spent more time engaging with
german
that i might start to get a feel for how
these words are used but talking about
the
turkish verbs and it's that the biggest
problem i'm having right now so
one of the things i do is i find
different sites on the internet and i
print these things out so i can also
because anything we do we can do them in
different ways so i do it on the
computer i do it on my ipad i have paper
i have book different ways of covering
the same material i find this very
helpful
and i have a sauna at home
and i like taking these into the sauna
as opposed to my ipad so
they say turkish verbs of condition
there are some verbs in the turkish
vocabulary that already have a
conditional feeling within themselves he
tells us
and
there are
various kinds of conditional turkish
future negative conditional turkish real
past negative conditional
uh turkish continuous negative
conditional turkish habitual negative
conditional turkish
real
past conditional unreal past conditional
simple negative conditional
simple habitual conditional future
intentional conditional
conditional positive present can anyway
it just goes on and on
i will show you
uh just how many different forms there
are of the verb there is no way that i
can possibly remember this stuff and yet
and as i struggle in my conversation
with my tutor to try to hit
you know out of the 25 potential forms
to try to hit the right one and of
course i don't come close
but i know
that from previous experience that in
time with enough exposure i'll get used
to it and the advantage in turkish is
that it's written in the latin alphabet
so i have read
in six weeks i've read more turkish than
i have read arabic or farsi because it's
so difficult for me to read in a strange
alphabet so now let me show you a little
bit about the
conjugations and also the um
tutors report on my computer and then
i'll follow up end okay so here we are
looking at my computer and i am oh
uh we won't go there first i was going
to show you
where are we here we are in turkish okay
so if i look up a verb
here gilmay
uh
doesn't really matter which one we take
we'll take this so i look up my
dictionaries
and uh
i will look at the verbic verb
conjugated dictionary
give you a sense of the complexity
uh so this is a good dictionary sorry by
the way i also like to use a cool
jugator but they often return no results
in turkish so i tend to stick with
verbix
and so if we start typing we i could
start typing you know something or other
and go to yapmak
or i can look at some of the verbs that
they
the top 10 turkish verbs conjugated it
doesn't much matter let's just hit
yapmai
so
here we go which means to do
and
so if we spread that out here so we have
the initiative mood we have both a
continuous and a simple form
we have the past definite past
progressive indefinite past past
progressive narrative past perfect
narrative doubtful distant past all
different for different
uh persons
and we have the past in the future
there's a good one past conditional
narrative past conditional dubitative
this is where
it's past and conditional but maybe it
didn't happen but it seems it might have
happened or something future simple
future dubit at the future in the past
future conditional
necessitative mood tenses
past duplicative imperative conditional
tenses simple tense progressive past
hour is present indefinite
subjunctive mood tenses
simple past reportative
and whatever so
obviously there is no way that anyone
can learn this like i could study this
till i'm blue in the face and i won't
remember it however i am quite convinced
that if i continue to go through and
this happens to be from a conversation
report this text which i can also listen
to by the way
[Music]
okay so if i continue engaging with the
content i will eventually get there
now
there was a question
about so and so the the i just want to
leave you with that when i come across a
verb okay seviorum
okay so here again i look up that
dictionary
i go to or which in the case of
verbix i have to type in seviorum and
then i can very quickly review and pick
basically identify where this one is and
and every time i go to the verb
you know it just helps so i do the same
in say spanish i go to
whatever conjugating dictionary and
there we have conjugating dictionaries
in all the i would say all but mostly
different
context reverso is a good one which i
used
for arabic
and so i just find that going it also
exists for hebrew
greek
i go there you can do it for spanish
french and i kind of look through these
tables
don't expect to remember anything and
then get backs to the text because
obviously ultimately it's engaging with
enough content so the the trick is to
initially work with the sort of mini
story type repetitive material and then
find enough interesting meaningful
content at a level you can deal with so
that you engage enough with the language
and in that way you will eventually get
there now
i just wanted to finish off with
uh people were asking about the
conversation report so here's one that i
did for marcin who is uh polish
and so i in my conversation report here
at link i wrote out four sentences
which basically embodied
all of the
sort of
places where i thought he maybe wasn't
100 sure he is an excellent speaker of
english so there weren't very many
outright errors but there's no harm in
giving him
content content that will be
sort of relevant because it relates to
things that we were talking about so
this is a in a sense a
sort of a a
summary or a distilled essence
of
our conversation and then in the comment
section
uh i generally like to put something in
there
the main purpose of the comments section
is to encourage the learner so i as a
tutor
uh you know i'm not that interested in
having people take english with me
online
but if i'm trying to promote my services
as a tutor i would say something
positive here i enjoyed the conversation
i hope you you know that you come back
again and and maybe something
if there's an overall area that the
person needs to work on i might mention
it here and then i have recorded the
thing
monday july 8th marching
you gave me hope
okay i so that is the report and that
report goes to the student who can then
click on it and import it as a lesson
so if i look at myself as a learner if i
look at say farsi
and
persian so let's see somewhere in here
are my conversation reports so i open my
conversation reports
and what i see is
wait for them to open here
um
sometimes a little slower or when i'm in
loom
so august 20th so i started august 20th
so i have here
of all of my conversations with
essentially two two tutors nazi and rana
and i can go back to any one of them and
review the conversation that we had
and it includes a recording in every
case
uh i can even
uh listen to these recordings one after
another if i
basically
because we have the ability and i tend
to listen
mostly on the app i have the ability to
say listen to the audio for the whole
course so these conversation reports
are a course and if i'm listening
through these typically they're three
four five minutes long
and i come across words that i have
already forgotten
then i can go in and open it up and
work through it again
so in the case of farsi i go back to
august 20th 2018
if i go now to
arabic
then
actually i go back so september 11th
2018 november so i go back here
to
august 8 2018
uh november 14th so i can go through all
of these i can listen to them
but if i
look at languages that i've been at
longer
like russian for example
uh
and here for whatever reason they're
organized with the most recent one first
so wait for it to open here for a sec
and as i say it's slower for some reason
when i'm on zoom
by the way notice the 90 so
august the 9th
2017
was the last time i spoke
but if i
go to the bottom here
i mean there are a lot these are all my
conversations in russian i can review
and review all
and how far back does it go
how far back does it go to 2012
2012.
my goodness i'd forgotten 2011.
oh 2010
2010.
2009
december 2009
november anyway you get the point so i
can review
all of these i can listen to all of them
where audio is provided so i hope that
gives you a sense of how this whole
business with the now some of these
tutors were on link some of these tutors
were on italki and i simply uh copy the
google document or whatever that i get
and the mp3 recording and i import it
as a
as a lesson
but
so i covered two topics today one was
actually we'll just uh maybe i'll just
go back to the
iphone view here and uh now
yeah so
two things that i wanted to cover well
more than two three or four items today
one was the issue of conjugations which
is a a big issue
this is conjugations or declensions in
some languages these tables that people
try so hard to memorize and learn i've
never found that effective
it's it's again a matter of exposing
yourself to a nice enough content that
it starts to become
sort of a habit and then you review the
tables and it reminds you of something
that you have experienced and i find
that in that way we gradually get better
i have no doubt that with enough time i
will eventually be able to use these
turkish verbs more and more correctly
with errors but gradually getting better
and better
uh also i showed you some examples
people asked for examples of the tutors
reports
i've spoken with a tutor now four times
in turkish and i'll continue doing so
i eventually want to get back to my
persian and arabic so that i don't
forget them but i want to push a little
further in my turkish
and as i say uh don't forget to sign up
for long fest if you haven't done so use
my name steve as an access code to get a
discount
and if you're interested check out the
podcast with chris brohom
you'll find links to both of those in
the description box thank you for
listening bye for now